- Turn fear on itself.
- Feel fear quite strongly.
- Fear is the fuel.
- ...Undoes the fear.
- I grandiose my way out of fear.
- Fear.
- Embrace that fear.
- Transcend that fear.
- Hello believe nation,
my name Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the worlds major challenges.
And so to help you on your mission,
today we're going to learn how
you can overcome your fears.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the video,
if something really speaks to you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well, enjoy.
(grandiose orchestra music)
- The only way to deal with fear
that I've found in my
life is a couple ways.
One of those ways is to turn it on itself
and ask yourself what am I afraid of?
I'm afraid of that?
I've got to be more afraid of what
I'm going to miss out on,
missing out on my mission,
missing out on who I'm supposed to be.
In other words, if you're
not going to get rid of fear
then use fear, use fear or it
uses you, it's that simple.
So you got to say okay, what's the price
if I just stay doing
this, what's the price?
I mean, I can really get scared
if I learn all this and
I don't follow through.
That's something to be scared about.
And then that fear will
get you over your fear,
it'll push you through,
turn fear on itself.
Second way you can do it is use what
you've probably heard me
say, 'cause I've used it
since I was 17, is my little
rocking chair test, right?
I'm going to sit myself
in my rocking chair,
I'm 85 years old, I'm
looking back on my life,
and say I didn't do this, or I did.
- You're unusually
fearless and willing to go
in the face of other people
telling you it's crazy.
And I know a lot of pretty crazy people,
you still stand out.
Where does that come
from or how do you think
about making a decision when everyone
tells you this is a crazy idea?
Where do you get the
internal strength to do that?
- Well first of all,
I'd say I actually think
I feel fear quite strongly,
so it's not as though
I just have the absence of fear,
I feel it quite strongly.
But there are just times when something
is important enough, you
believe in it enough,
that you do it in spite of the fear.
- So speaking of important things...
- People shouldn't think,
well I feel fear about this
and therefore I shouldn't do it.
It's normal to feel fear,
like there'd have to be
something mentally wrong
if you didn't feel fear.
- So you just feel it
and let the importance
of it drive you to do it anyway?
- Yeah, actually something
that can be helpful
is fatalism, to some degree.
If you just accept the probabilities
then that diminishes fear.
When starting SpaceX I
thought the odds of success
were less than 10%, and I just accepted
that actually, probably, I
would just lose everything,
but that maybe we'd make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward,
even if we died, maybe
some other company could
pick up the baton and
keep moving it forward,
so that we'll still do some good.
Yeah, same with Tesla.
I thought the odds of a car company
succeeding were extremely low.
- There's always fear and
I even put it in Rocky 3
that, you know, he's
'I'm afraid, I'm afraid'.
But the fear is the fuel that
we use for overachievement.
If I wasn't afraid at times
I wouldn't work as hard
because the fear is, I
don't want to slip back
into mediocrity, I don't want to just say,
okay I want to rest on my laurels.
So I hear footsteps all the time,
and I know that I only have
a certain amount of time
and I don't want to waste it
because it's gone so quickly.
Since Rocky it's been almost
seven and a half, eight years,
and I think Talia and I
are just overachievers
because we know that
there's only a certain
amount of productivity in a day
and we don't want to waste it.
- I'm a writer, I'm supposed
to be behind the scenes
and everybody else is supposed
to be in front of the stuff.
- Now she's finally in
front of the camera.
The famously private woman talking
about her epic struggles with anxiety
and her fear of public speaking.
What physiologically
happens when you're having
that stage four panic attack?
- There's a little bit
of panicked breathing,
there's a lot of pacing back
and forth and mumbling to myself.
- [Reporter] Despite being
invited to every glamorous
party in Hollywood, she'd make excuses
saying she was just too busy,
until one day her sister provoked her.
- I was sort of going on
and on about all of the
invitations that I'd received.
And my sister finally cut in and said
are you going to say yes
to any of these things?
And I remember being very taken aback
and saying no I'm busy I can't,
And her sort of looking
at me like, that's insane,
and at some point just saying,
you never say yes to anything.
And those words really sticking with me,
because she was right.
- And so this became a campaign to say
yes to the things that scared you.
- Yeah, to say yes to the
things that freaked me out.
- And when you started saying
yes, what started to happen?
- It's the doing of the thing
that sort of undoes the fear.
- When you experience
moments of self-doubt,
how do you approach getting
out of that dark place?
- [Woman] Good question.
- I grandiose my way out of fear.
(laughing)
- [Robert] If you could imagine that.
(laughing and applause)
- [Woman] It's a good way, it's charming.
- Literally it's like, okay,
I'm going to do one of the
greatest car chases of all time.
And if I don't I'm not as
talented as I thought I was.
(audience laughs)
And I will realize that there
is a ceiling to my talent,
right now I don't think there
is, but if I don't do...
(audience laughs)
But if it's not one of the
greatest car chases of all time,
then I failed and there
is a ceiling to my talent,
I'm not as good as I thought I was.
And I said that to
everybody, and was I scared?
(blank) yeah, I had
trepidation going all the way,
'cause it's mine to fail, and it's failing
in front of the mirror
too, 'cause I'll know
if I did it or not and I'll be like,
okay, you were not as good
as you thought you were.
And that got me to Mount Everest.
- It's true, I remember
at one point he goes,
Robert, can you imagine you
and me doing this car chase
together, how great it's going to be?
And I'm like hey man,
you're on your own brother.
(laughing)
I ain't going out there man,
I got five (blank) kids.
I'm not going to do no hundred
mile an hour bull(blank).
You want to live the Vanishing
Point dream buddy? Live it.
(laughing)
And he did it all by himself
and I'm so (blank) proud of him.
- [Interviewer] Is that
the big difference between,
'cause I see you in your
basement like a Batman
with all machines and stuff.
It's really precise, I guess, and really
you know what you put
and then you go live.
What's the difference, the risk?
- The risk, you know and the risk...
I have stage fright and I
never confronted the risk,
or when I did confront, you
know Belgium, year 2000.
That was, you have no idea what
it took then to get me to do it.
- [Interviewer] And why did you say yes?
- I had 1000 excuses why not do it,
and then finally I did it, and it was...
Exquisitely horrifying, that's
the only way I can put it.
- [Interviewer] Complex.
- Yes, it was very very very complex.
And what was really good,
was right at the beginning,
within like two seconds,
I played just the worst
wrong note, and I could
either stop and cry,
or I could laugh, alright?
And it didn't kill me,
and nobody else out there,
nobody was throwing anything,
you know? It was fine.
Thank you to the people of
Ghent for not killing me
and giving me the courage.
And the absurdity, you have to
be able to laugh at yourself.
And you have to learn
how to laugh at yourself.
- If you say I'm a fraud,
they'll figure me out,
I'll never be able to do it again,
that's an artist's thought
process, you're an artist.
If you're thinking like that, then you're
on the right track,
because they all fell that.
So there's always some
success that can come out
even out of your
failures, in fact probably
your biggest successes will come
directly from your failures.
So you should almost, take that Winston
Churchill quote, it's my favorite.
"Success is moving from one failure
to the next with great enthusiasm."
You should be very enthusiastic
about your failures
because you're going to learn something.
You're going to go that
way when everyone else
is going that way, and
you're going to stumble,
but you're also going to
stumble upon something
that no one ever thought of.
So you know, you just
keep going and keep going
and you're going to fail and then rise up
and then fail again,
and that's the journey.
Up and down, man.
- Most of us that come from
just normal backgrounds,
we don't see ourselves
doing abnormal things.
The world is full of people
who were born on third
and think they hit a
triple and they've got
all this confidence, all this stuff.
For most of us, it's not that way.
We don't think we're wired
or programmed to do something great.
Well I'm telling ya, that
thought is nothing but a fear.
Nothing but a doubt, it's
what holds you in place.
You got to work hard on
understanding you have within you
the power to change, the
power to do something great.
And those fears are going
to crop up particularly
in the middle of the
night when you wake up
and you're scared to
death about what to do.
They're going to crop up and
they're going to hold you in place.
Quite often if you're
trying something different
they crop up in the middle of your dreams,
when you're asleep at night those
fears and doubts creep in.
Understand they're not
real, they are things
in your head that have been programmed
into you by your past life.
Wrestle with those fears,
you'll never conquer them
but control them, and go out
and live the life you deserve.
Choose to win, control your
thinking, and go win big.
- And whenever people
reach out to me and say
I'm doubting what I'm doing, I say well,
congratulations, you're a human being.
That's what it means to be a human.
- High five.
- You doubt what you do, it's
that voice inside our head.
It's innate in all of us, we're born
with the imposter syndrome, so we don't
walk outside in the dark
with a saber-tooth tiger.
It's like there's a voice
saying don't walk outside,
it's dangerous, but we
don't live in that same
world anymore, but we still
have that inside our head.
And that's fine, but we
need to learn not to let
it control our lives,
but to embrace that fear.
So I still have it every single day.
We talked about my revenue last month,
I still wake up and say man,
should I do this webinar?
I have these doubts and these fears,
and that's just a reality and I've
just learned to embrace that.
- What's the first step to overcoming
the fear or transforming the fear?
- To witness it, to be the nonjudgmental
witness of it, to look at it and say
something's got to give, right?
So if you're unwilling to
look at your fear head-on
and honor it and, I always
say, if you don't show
up for what's up it will keep showing up.
So looking and saying I
witness my resistance,
and you see that fear as resistance,
fear is a resistance to
what it is you desire.
And in the absence of
resistance you become
a magnet for what you desire.
When you let go of that
fear and you transcend
that fear that's when you start to become
a super attractor,
that's when you start to
let what is truly of essence
for you into your life,
what is truly of service
what is true happiness into your life.
And so looking at the fear, witnessing it,
and calling it by it's name,
and even if you don't have the tools yet,
what happens is when you look at the fear
and your like, oh I see this
fear, I see this resistance,
I see how it's blocking my life,
and I choose to see it differently.
That's when you're listening
to an audio like this.
That's when a book like yours
will fall off the shelf.
- [Man] A catalyst to open up.
- Exactly, you open up your
consciousness, pretty much.
You crack open your
consciousness to find solutions
rather than find problems,
and so when you're not
looking at the fear, you're
just living in the fear
and you're believing in the problem.
But when you witness the
fear and you're willing
to see it differently, you
start living in the solution.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
What clips spoke to you the most?
What are you going to take from this video
and immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Ryan Saplan.
Ryan, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, 'Your One Word', and offering
to do a review on it for your blog.
I really really really
appreciate the support
man and I hope you enjoy the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself, and
whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.